very recently the government
acknowledged the existence of UFOs
they're real and that is objectively
incredible but what I find more
incredible is the fact that when the
government comes out and says UFOs are
real seemingly nobody cares they call
him UAP um unidentified anomalous
phenomena because UFO was in lie of
flying saucer but now we know they're
under the water they're in space like
this is documented it's so unidentified
an Lous phenomena as new government term
we don't know who operates them and they
appear to be able to do things that our
own weapon systems can't so you're right
they've said UFOs are real we're no
closer to understanding what a UFO truly
is who operates them where are they from
what's the intent what they represent to
humankind so the public in general they
see that on the news it's like okay yeah
we all kind of thought that cuz we're
seeing them thanks government right but
nothing's really answered